hello ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls people from around the world John
Perry here welcome to another Sunday
morning science it's been a while since
I've done this I apologize but I'm I'm
dedicated to making this a thing during
at least during the coronavirus lockdown
so I will be here every Sunday morning
at 11 a.m. Eastern Time that's I think 8
a.m. Pacific time and just to get things
rolling here I would like to see
everybody send a send me a little note
in the comments tell me where you're
from and tell me what time it is where
you're at so let's let's do that here
for a second I've got some music what is
this music here it is Tim play acapella
science give you a little background
[Music]
we in the comments so what are we gonna
do today we're going to learn about well
conspiracies we're going to look at the
comments on the stated clearly animation
that I did the where did new viruses
come from and we're gonna look at some
other things have been asked some of the
questions that have been asked in there
and we're going to look at the how some
of the conspiracies that have been sent
my way I've had a very interesting view
of the mindset of the people about this
virus because of that video I launched
it before the virus hit the United
States and so I kind of watched as
everyone's ideas about it changed over
time
so it'll be right I'll be interesting to
see that we've only got one right now
that says oh we got one
hi front row a fro that's good hi hi
from India Wow what time is he what time
was it in India what time is there about
directly opposite of us I think great
its bed at 11 or 12 hours difference
from I'm here in the East Coast's to
India well yeah I wonder how many time
zones there are in India though that's a
good point I do not know um tell us what
time it is hey Ann Smith is here from
from my crew alright I'm from California
Han Smith so so I'm assuming it's like a
dish in California a dish we got we got
Argentina got Toronto
yeah and Smith says it's 8 a.m. here and
then yeah it's 834 in India 1834 p.m.
the directly opposite of we've gotten
hello from Austria hi uh hi from Austria
sir
a high from Brazil and good morning from
Scott Perry my dad hey Scott he's never
talked by Lake your son
he's only he's on the west coast ain't
there it's 6 p.m. in Israel 5 p.m. in
Austria 1705 in Norway guess Ottawa
Canada I'm lemon we use 24 like use
French french-canadian 24-hour time
around here yeah I changed my name oh
I'd changed my phone in military time so
I could get used to it when people tell
me it's like you know makes more sense
to me although if I were reorient in
reorienting time I don't know what I
would do maybe I'd probably do time in
radians I think time in radians yeah I
think we'd have six point two eight
hours in the day and it you divide it up
like that makes more sense to me and
then like there's sort of I don't know
then there's like four blocks of the day
where you're awake and like to where
you're asleep I feel like it can make
sense you do like four radians awake and
two radians asleep and that gives you
like just a little over eight hours
which I it'd be like to point to eight I
think that's really what you want
eight hours isn't quite enough I agree
there's not quite enough
in fact that's that's one of the reasons
that Sunday morning science stand you
know I took a break from it cuz it's
Stuart
you were you were staying up late in the
evenings yeah yeah I understand it's so
easy like when you're with your youtuber
at home alone I have to get up I have to
actually do the things today
no one's forcing me to I'm just slightly
hampering my own career but like that's
on me I'd love to report to anybody yeah
yeah surely these friends these fans
won't miss me I like that I've been
doing daily streams because like and
like I've made that kind of a promise
because if I was doing like whenever I
feel like yeah I would I would just do
it once and then never do it again I
think yeah like but it's but it's
surprising how often like once I've done
10 minutes of the stream it like opens
me up and then I feel like doing it I
don't know I think there's a general
like principle to that ya know what live
streaming stuff is pretty fun and we got
a couple more people we got talk beliefs
from London 1605 over there we've got
one two three SSS dee dee dee from Saudi
Arabia at 6:05 p.m. great and Ann Smith
says getting up early justifies taking a
nap so that is definitely correct that
can be your 0.28 radians just like yeah
a bit in the middle yeah yeah so today
let's jump into some science here all
right I've got on on this new animation
and I don't know if everyone's seen it
but it's doing really well it's almost
it's almost at three million views it's
a cheese man nothing's going to point
nine million views the new animation
stated clearly viral man I might I say
yeah and it really did follow the curve
for a while of infections in the u.s.
it's now starting to flatten out which
is what we want to see the virus do but
unfortunately in my case or in the
world's case or in America's case that's
not why my video is flattening out my
video is flattening out because now
there's a billion other videos about the
virus but yeah the you can't just take
the whole nice to yourself now it's a
good niche you're gonna get competition
yeah
so that's but we got a lot of really
good questions in the comments there you
know a couple weeks ago I did a stream
about questions that my my patreon
supporters had and today I just want to
go over some of the quote well we're
gonna do one at least one question from
the comments there
and then look at some of the crazy
conspiracies so
the question which I've gotten a bunch
of different times and a bunch of
different variations is really
interesting because it reminds me of
when I first started learning about
evolution and trying to understand how
it worked and I think that if we can
answer this question properly we can
teach evolution to anyone and the
question was why do viruses exist
they're not sentient so what is the
point of their existence and this is a
very it's almost laughably simple if
you've been understanding biology for a
long time but this really is something
that really bothers people when they're
first starting to learn about biology
why and it raised a like a framework of
thinking which is kind of like the
default human framework I think it's
like as as old as people which is that
things exist because they have purposes
for them to exist right that's that's as
old as Aristotle saying that you know
the purpose of Earth was to fall this is
this is really the way that we the way
that we make sense of the world I think
is the default and I think you kind of
have to be trained out of it yeah okay
so why do i do viruses exist so do you
want like how should we like you up you
want me to start building up the physics
of it and then you can you can take it
from there
well yeah so one of the things the other
versions of this question is is um if
something doesn't have a will to live
why is it alive or why is it doing what
it's doing and again you know some
biologists don't consider viruses to be
alive but I mean it's kind of silly they
evolve they reproduce they have genes
they so essentially they think you can
actually destroy them you can stop them
from living so to try and say that
viruses aren't alive as kind of a little
bit of a silly argument but I think
they're definitely part of this this
overall thing that we
call life right and and if you watch a
virus behave it seems as though it's
striving to do something it's trying to
do something and I noticed that in
physics we get this all the time as well
people say that a photon is trying to
travel from point A to point B and so
yeah I think I think to start out with
what the physics of things would be good
you're you're back on this um cuz 10
yeah for those who don't know is it he
does physics I saw it
if you want my credentials yeah I did an
undergrad and then a master's in
theoretical physics way back in the day
graduated in 2013 from McGill University
which is well we like to say that
Harvard is the McGill of America and we
and then I I got out of research and I
decided to make a make youtube videos
and said so make new musical YouTube
videos so that's my background I mean so
I think I'm probably gonna have to hand
it over to you pretty early because like
you know you know a lot more about the
origin of life stuff than I do even in
terms of like like the chemical
evolution part of it
mm-hmm but it is generally well is it it
is the case that the laws of physics
don't really put reasons into them for
things that are acting under them so
they're like it turns out that reality
is sort of remarkably simple and it it
wouldn't have been obvious I don't think
from like before definitely before the
20th century that reality was was so
simple like it started to we started to
find kind of coherent laws for things
you know Newton was kind of the Galileo
and then Newton were kind of the first
to really set that down but it's just
been this process of like collating and
simplifying and realizing that all these
phenomena we thought were completely
disparate phenomena that life was this
effort kept separate category or heat
was the
separate category really are like on the
fundamental level they're all the
results of the same basic mathematical
equations the same four forces and a few
different matter fields that are
interacting in very specific and known
ways and those like those laws
themselves don't have any teleology to
them they don't have they're not trying
to achieve anything they take the state
of the world as it is and they evolve it
forward deterministically to a new state
what makes all the complexity in the
world is just that the world is complex
like the state of the world for whatever
reason is very complicated there's a lot
of information in it and when you go
forward from from one complicated one
complicated state you evolve it forward
in time you're gonna get another
complicated interesting state and like
the universe is so vast that many
interesting things can happen randomly
now there's a limit to how to how much
randomness like how much structure can
come just from pure numbers right yeah
so like you you hear when you hear like
a creationist say like you you can't
imagine that I've you know like a cell
could come out of like literal
randomness because that's unlikely as
like a hurricane assembling a fighter
jet that's entirely true yeah like if
that were the only process going on it's
connected attempting to reconnect and
shoot we are reconnected are we
reconnected are we back someone tell us
some that you had a fir back we are back
yep ok cool ok um so like if you if
you're trying to assemble a squirrel I
would have random jostling the particles
not to not to easy to do that like it
just you would need more particles than
there are in the observable universe do
that out of randomness but when you're
talking about assembling a few like a
few amino acids into a little chain that
folds up and does
thing interesting that's something
that's very feasible to come out of
randomness in fact we can you know we
can do experiments showing that we can
get those in small laboratory settings
and even if we're you know even if we're
a lot better at making the conditions
just right in the laboratory the earth
has the resources of the entire earth
over which to perform that experiment
not to mention that there's a selection
effect that we happen to be on earth I
mean there's there we now know of 10,000
planets in the in our galaxy the only
reason we only know of 10,000 is because
mostly we looked at one little tiny spot
and we saw all of them in that spot so
it's a there's more than enough numbers
to put together accidental little
machines that might do something
interesting and most interesting of all
might be of a sort of configuration
where they can catalyze the production
of more little molecules like them
exactly and I think that's that's where
I would kick it off to you and ask well
where does it go from there all right
yeah so the process of evolution is just
a natural process that arises when you
have some sort of a system that can make
copies of itself and some of those
copies are imperfect so you've got a
thing that can replicate itself with
slight imperfections and what that
produces is what Darwin called descent
with modification so parents have
offspring and some of those offspring is
slightly different than their parents
and slightly different than each other
and that causes a natural competition to
emerge an automatic competition to
emerge some of these individuals some of
these offspring are going to be even
better at copying themselves than their
parents were and better at copying
themselves than their siblings are and
there's going to be limited resources
and in any given environment and so
there's gonna be a competition for those
resources and even if there's not
limited resources it's just whoever is
faster and more accurate at reproducing
there's going to be more of them in
existence than the other things
so there's kind of there's two ways and
there are several ways to exist in the
universe one way is you can be really
stable so like a rock
rocks are common on earth because once
they form they stick around for a long
time even though it's pretty rare for a
rock to form once it forms it's just
there for a long time so we've got lots
of rocks on earth solid rocks the other
way to exist this to be super easy to
come into existence so snowflakes form
rapidly hidden form constantly if you're
in a cold enough environment so
snowflakes are super common when you are
in a cold environment but they're also
very fragile it doesn't matter because
they're constantly being produced and
they constantly melt but they're it's
it's it's always happening and then the
other way to be common in the universe
is to make copies of yourself and that's
that was the big innovation that
happened somehow at the start of life we
don't know how we don't know what that
first replicator was but there was a
molecule possibly something similar to
RNA that could make copies of itself it
could catalyze the chemical reaction of
molecules in its environment to make a
copy of itself and some of them did so
better than others and through copying
errors we got variation and how good
those copiers were so yeah I think like
like I I find that if I think about it
in terms of like a single replicating
thing the crew like and I like just
simulate the actual numbers in my head
there's this kind of inevitability
inevitability that kicks in with it
right so so suppose you have a single
thing that can make two copies of itself
right so you have that thing and it
makes two copies and now there are two
of them or those gonna do they're
exactly the same they're going to make
two more copy two more copies each now
you've got four of them so this is the
classic exponential rabbits or readily
pads or whatever it is but suppose on
the on the third copying there's a
slight error in one of them and now
you've got seven of the old one but one
of the new
but the new one can make three copies of
itself right maybe there was a slight I
mean there's probably other ones that
can make no copies of themselves so
let's put one in there that one's gonna
immediately the line will die with that
thing there won't be any more of it it's
gone right so all of all of the
randomness that causes negatives is
immediately taken out of the next step
so you've got this bias towards
positives and then you have this one
that can make three copies of itself in
the next step it's already got three the
others are still doubling but this one's
now tripling so now you've got sixteen
and three and then you've got 32 and
nine and then you've got 64 and 27 and
then you've got 128 and 81 on the next
step the one that became the one that
was able to divide three times is
already passing all of the others in
terms of absolute number and and it's
it's taking over the population and then
as soon as there's some sort of pressure
that's going to winnow down the amount
of of total things say that say every
step it lops off half yeah
then your fraction of the the better
replicant just grows and grows and grows
until it takes over so now lo and behold
you've got a molecule that are a little
machine that replicates better than the
original one and if you didn't there was
no there was no will of any individual
molecule deciding that it was trying to
get better at replicating or that it was
going to pursue the strategy that made
it more efficient it's just a law of
numbers that I think that's more
efficient is going to take over and
raise this just continually happens yeah
that people people say that so there's
the saying survival of the fittest and
people criticize that saying well that's
just it's not even saying anything it's
like survival but what it means to be
fit as far as evolution goes is that
you're good at surviving and reproducing
you know survival of the fittest means
survival of those that survive
it's it's a reproduction of those three
videos yeah and and it really is that
simple that's how that's how stupidly
simple the the foundation
evolution is its you've got a replicator
and it's the ones that replicate best
replicate best and so there's more of
them and that's really the end of the
story now the the competition comes of
course because when you have exponential
growth there's going to be you know
these replicators aren't making copies
of themselves out of nothing their tape
they're transforming chemicals in their
environment into copies of themselves so
they're they're taking atoms and
assembling them in a way that is makes a
copy of themselves so there is there are
limited resources in any environment and
the skills you need to have to replicate
yourself are gonna be different in
different environments so as what's
gonna happen is you have this population
that butts up against the borders of its
particular environment where this sort
of chemistry it's been doing so far is
easy for it to do and then you're gonna
have there's going to be another
environment where it's harder to do and
eventually you'll get some luck could
have it so that you can actually get one
version of the replicator to spit out
into this new environment and have a
slight chance of making it out there and
once evolution pulls that organism to be
good at reproducing in that new
environment now you've got two different
species that that use very different
chemistry's to do what they're doing and
so you get a diversity of life and
that's that's it
these things do not have a will these
early replicators did not have a will a
will to survive as you and I would
understand it as an animal would
understand it that's a very new trait
and we should think of a will to survive
just as a trait that helps an organism
that has a brain survive and it's a it's
a trait that if you if you have a
nervous system and you develop a will to
survive will help you survive right
right that's that's seems also pretty I
don't pretty intuitive yeah so you would
imagine that as soon as you have a
nervous system it will
survive will preferentially replicate
and survive better than one that is
absent yeah it's a survival trait just
like having a horn on your head is a
survival trait if you are a you know cow
but it's one that it's not it's not open
to a virus the virus doesn't have the
machinery to have a will to survive
correct but it has meant it has lots of
other mechanisms or I wish to survive
and reproduce and it uses them yeah and
I think I think this this will to
survive is something to that it only
becomes important when a nervous system
is super complex so if you look at
really simple animals like a jellyfish
for example the jellyfish will have a
nervous system it's very simple it's got
these little nodes of nerves and it
causes the jellyfish to swim and some
jellyfish are attracted to light so
they'll swim towards light and so there
they just when there's when things are
getting dimmer there's kind of we don't
know what it's like to be a jellyfish
but you could imagine it's kind of like
the alarms going off like you're going
the wrong way and so it it it's
movements change in a very it's really
it's just computing it's it's there's a
sensory input in that sensory input
changes it it causes it to change its
direction it disturbs it and at once
that so it's it's driven to go in a
different direction until it's starting
to get brighter and brighter and then
it's it's it calms down and like the
borders between at some point the
borders between mechanism and and
conscious will do start to get fuzzy
though right and I think that's where we
I don't know for me that's where I bump
up against the limit of my understanding
I think I bump up against the limit of
pretty much everyone's understanding
like where where this this feeling of
conscious will that humans have like
where it originates and how far down it
goes and how you can really separate it
from a simple neural signal to swim
towards light or towards food
or away from predators or whatever
that's definitely I mean there's
definitely still something mysterious
about that from the point of view like
like we don't we haven't codified what
is happening I don't think right so so
if I understand what you're saying
you're saying I'm you know we we can
kind of understand a jellyfish by a
simple computation right well it's it's
like we don't really know like you u.s.
you said we don't know what it's like to
be a jellyfish we don't really know if
there's something that it's like to be a
jellyfish right correct and and we don't
know when when the kind of the lights of
consciousness and having a will to do
things we don't know exactly when that
switch is on and fully why except for
that it it seems to be an adaptation to
help us focus right yeah like you can
imagine that there is a at some point
you need like as a central something
like a central plan like as soon as your
nervous system is complex enough that it
can do complex planning you might need a
central kind of logical rational
planning part of it that has access to
everything else just because it's more
efficient to to be able to plan top-down
like that and it seems to me that
consciousness is in some way connected
into that but I am in no way an expert
in consciousness so maybe I should stop
talking yeah this question of sentience
is actually does get pretty complicated
but we can't answer this question why do
viruses exist they're not sentient what
is the point of their existence and
viruses exists because they replicate
and they replicate is they've been
replicating and replicating exists
because they can exist and lots of
things happen in an immense universe
all right so evolution is happening
evolution is causing them to this simple
process of descent with modification
which because because they have genes
and they make
of those genes and sometimes there's
copying errors when it those genes are
being made we have descent with
modification in viruses they make copies
of themselves they use our cells to make
copies of themselves so they get inside
of a cell
they hijack its machinery and the cells
machinery makes a copy of the virus
actually makes thousands of copies of
the virus some of those copies are not
exactly the same as the original and so
you have descent with modification and
because you have descent with
modification there's an automatic
competition survival of the fittest that
happens amongst viruses and they
actually compete with each other to
infect new cells and continue their
process and that is why viruses exist
and it's not it has nothing to do with
scent being sentient so far as we know
there's nothing remotely similar to
sentient what we experience being alive
there's nothing similar to that at all
and a virus or in a bacteria yeah these
are very and yet like isms like the ways
that they have like through this
iterated process over you know who knows
how long a billion years the ways that
the strategies that they have stumbled
into if they were planned by something
conscious would be brilliant a lot of
the time yeah like it's it's like the
idea that you've got a you've got a
retrovirus that's a bit of RNA that
actually encodes within it a protein to
convert its RNA into DNA and put that
DNA into your cells so that your own
machinery it
like not only replicates the virus
within that cell for a period of time
but you have that virus in your DNA for
the rest of your life
that's brilliant I don't think I would
have you know I don't think I would have
thought of that as someone planning
virus this and there's like it's been
interesting to me seeing the way people
are like when people are doing analyses
of kovat and whether or not it's like
it's man-made and their conclusion
is it it doesn't look man-made because
we wouldn't have been able to do this
like the mechanism that it uses to
attach to your to your like ace
receptors was not known to us right and
we wouldn't have thought to do it but it
works yeah
so yeah we will talk about some of these
conspiracies here in a minute
I sorry I I was half paying attention to
you because I was trying to read the
comments okay we froze again did you say
that did you say that the coronavirus
inserts its DNA into our genome no no
this is a mistake that brent weinstein
actually made on his live stream a
couple days ago i was a little
frustrated with him because he started
calling the coronavirus a retrovirus and
comparing it to HIV which is it is not
it is an RNA virus but it's not a
retrovirus it doesn't yeah so yeah for
those who don't know retroviruses
actually stick their genomes into our
genomes and they're yeah they're there
forever but this this virus does not do
that it's its genome free floats in the
cytoplasm so far as we know and it's
just replicated a bunch of times in
there and then gets encapsulated and
comes back out visit does it does it
replicate its it must replicate its RNA
somehow without using like like without
using our own machinery that makes RNA
from DNA so how does it do that it has
its own RNA replicase in its genome so
the so the virus gets into a cell it get
actually gets swallowed by the cell so
it's got a double membrane at this point
so there's two membranes surrounding
it's it's DNA because it's got the
cell's membrane that it used to swallow
it and it's got its own membrane that it
that it it it gains d'Or from a previous
cell yeah still from a previous cell and
those two membranes fuse which causes
the whole thing to open up and it's it's
RNA just spits out into this end of the
cytoplasm of the cell and it has I'm not
sure if this has pre-made proteins in it
don't think it does I when I first was
reading about it we didn't know and I
think that the original SARS does not
but it has a gene and it's the first
gene it's a so it's got this chain of
RNA this chain of RNA hooks up to a
ribosome of the cell so the ribosome is
the protein building machine that cells
have and it starts being read by that
ribosome any little tape of instructions
the ribosome goes long in it it makes
just the one protein which is the the
replicator protein yes so it makes an
RNA replicase there are other genes on
it as well obviously that that build all
the other parts of the virus and then
itself it it assembles and in one of the
internal membranes of the cell so cells
have a whole bunch of different
structures inside of them that have
membranes and some of them have
ribosomes in the membrane and so some of
these gene or some of these yeah some of
these genes connect to ribosomes that
are inside the membrane so it'll build
parts of the virus on the inside of an
inner membrane parts of the virus on the
outside and the whole thing forms to
create the virus particles the the full
mature viruses and then they go out and
they bud and they are they they are
secreted from the cell and they go in
fact the new cell it's absolutely
spectacular when they bite off from from
the from the cell membrane how do they
then get the spike protein outside of
them poking around as a corona yeah I
think I think when I said bud I think
that's wrong so it's okay it's it's
they're secreted so they're wrapped in a
double membrane when they when they get
to the cells actual membrane at that
point they're wrapped in a double
membrane that top membrane fuses with
the cell and spits out the the the the
virus as we know it okay so I'd love to
say I would love to see someone do like
a high quality animation of that I know
so
I'm sure I'm sure someone has I
definitely seen comic-strip type things
showing how it works
and I want something in her life at the
comments here I really been paying
attention to questions here but let's
see there's a bit of a bit of a
conversation going in the comments but
I'm not sure if much of it relates to us
so people are saying that they've been
tested and you know we're getting to an
interesting and very sobering part of
this infection we're now a lot of our
listeners some might actually be sick
and a lot of our listeners know someone
who is sick and we might even have
people who and know someone who's died
so this is getting a like you know where
we do these coronavirus live streams
that kind of the darker it's gonna get I
said yes this time goes on but we're
here to try and have fun and lift
spirits and this is a crazy time last
night I was just Marilyn
when I when I got done working I went
out into the living room and Marilyn was
watching a movie about World War one I
don't remember what the name of the
movie it was okay but it was just crazy
to me seeing that like it was hell on
earth I mean you can't you can't imagine
a worse scenario it's just explosions
and death and murder and torture and
horribleness for years we're just
shipping people to get slaughtered
we're yeah work we had this insane
project where we would mine pull metal
from all around the world pull it out of
the ground form it into weapons and just
dump it on Europe like just this
horrible nasty human project and then
when that was over everyone went home
after you know everyone who survived
this hellscape they went home and then
they got infected with the Spanish flu
which actually killed more people than
World War one or at least had it's
spiked there was a high it had a higher
spike than World War one ever had I'm
not sure if total numbers it killed more
people but I think it
I think it did because I mean the total
numbers are unclear as it was a you know
worldwide pandemic and not everybody had
the capability of keeping records right
but did the estimates that I've seen of
it were something something between
fifty and a hundred million people died
in the Spanish flu yeah it's insane
so think these people must have thought
it was the end of the world like well
just being in World War one you'd think
it's the end of the world like how could
anything get better after that and then
you had the Spanish flu so everything
does get better you're happy you go home
and then everyone you know is dying of
the flu it's like what when are we gonna
get a break and I just saw this a
tornado just hit the United State win
that went into that went through
Nashville like a couple weeks ago that
like stayed around it just kept circling
Nashville for I think a few hours and
tore a bunch of it apart but as I said
there's a new one now yeah there was one
yesterday just like insult to injury and
then in Montreal there's an earthquake
last night that yeah and then meanwhile
in Africa there's a gigantic plague of
locusts yeah but you know things always
been like this it's it's like there's
there's always catastrophes happening
and there's one after another and
there's no the thing with kind of random
events like this is that there's no
there's not a luck streak it's kind of
like a like things happen when things
happen and sometimes they overlap and
it's but it's just like it's terrifying
and and one of the things that was
interesting about the tornado that I saw
luckily it only injured a few people and
I don't think there's any deaths again
it was like the very first story that
was written about it and I don't even
remember the detail and I think we
usually we also put these things
together in narratives right like
they're a tornado is happening all over
the world all the time and most cell
during tornado season yeah well yeah but
like we wouldn't pay attention to them
especially I turned a small tornado that
only that like doesn't kill anyone
we would think oh that's an interesting
you know a news story that goes on
seven paper whatever well the thing is
yeah when we're in this sense of the
world is falling apart yeah
everything everything you can't help it
everything gets put together in your
head yeah the thing is it was in it
destroyed a shopping center so thank
goodness people didn't die or I only
said think people didn't die they've
reported that no one died but yeah I
guess the shopping centers are empty
then yeah yeah the shopping centers were
already empty because of the virus but
it is but think of the the economic
impact of that it's like the shop
shopping centers around the world are
already screwed right because of this
coronavirus shut down and now when your
shops all closed up you're like oh man
how are we gonna how are we gonna pay
our bills after this you know we had no
customers and then tornado hits that
might actually be good you're probably
insured for natural disasters in a way
that I have no idea if a pandemic covers
yeah yeah yeah maybe there was a
question here that I thought might be
interesting
it was the question if I'm presuming
that the answer is in a slight rewording
of the question but the question is how
do eradicated diseases come back like
measles for example it's from Ben so I
think I'm pretty sure that the answer to
that is that measles has not in fact
been or but was never in fact eradicated
yeah it might have been eradicated
locally in some population but it's like
there's there's a few diseases we've
eradicated we've eradicated smallpox it
took a lot of it took a lot of effort
like to eradicate a disease you not only
have to like large-scale vaccinate the
entire world but you have to like
there's all these little pockets where
it can hang out and like little clusters
that you you have to watch out for and
you really have to like track it down
and make sure that though like the last
case has gone out and there's none of it
anyway and I don't think we've ever done
that for me zhilie just yeah
sufficiently suppressed it and something
that I want to point out and this is you
know we're gonna get into some some of
the conspiracy theories here in a minute
but one of the terrifying things is that
smallpox is eradicated in the population
but we still we still have it in
laboratories and we know what its genome
is and because of that it can actually
be rebuilt by people who have the
technology and it's not that expensive I
mean compared to building like a nuclear
weapon building smallpox would be super
cheap I mean it yeah I mean yeah we do
have a smallpox vaccine so right yeah
yeah it would have to be tweaked but I
mean you could definitely if you want to
if you want if you wanted to do it it
would definitely cause problems because
you would have every vaccinate people
and true and I presume we're not really
producing smallpox vaccine at scale
anymore what would be the point
well actually we might be because we
know that it's a potential biological
weapon it's kept in several laboratories
at least two that are documentaries we
study them we actually do experiments
that manipulate them we can manipulate
viruses we can make a virus that works
in one animal we can mutate it so it
works in another animal this is actually
common practice in laboratories because
if you've got something that's that
works in bats and you want to see how it
works because you're worried it might
jump to humans
well the best thing to do is to mutate
it so that it works in mice because we
don't like to have laboratories full of
bats bats are hard to keep right keep
track of so we know how to mutate them
in ways it'll make them work and mice
and we also know how to mutate them in
ways it'll make them work in humans so
the knowledge is all there like and and
these are actually fairly routine
experiments that are done so there is a
very real reason that whenever a new
virus breaks out someone needs to be
worried about the fact that this might
be a laboratory this might be a
laboratory invention and it might be a
laboratory leak may be an accidental
leak or it might actually be a weapon
that was unleashed on purpose so
it's not crazy to think that it
something could be a laboratory leak or
a weapon what is crazy we will see in
the end the conspiracies is how specific
people get and how certain they are that
it was this or that when there is a new
virus that comes out the military looks
into it right away we have software to
tell if something was created knowing if
something was created it was mutated in
a laboratory using known techniques
there are some ways to get around that
like if you're if you really want to
hide the fact that it's a weapon it's
possible you could you could design a
virus through natural selection you
could use natural selection so that
nature you know this this process of a
descent with modification they were
talking about you give it the right
conditions and yes they're like an
accelerated breeding program yeah so
what you would I'm not gonna explain how
to do it but yeh let's not tell our
YouTube viewers how to create deadly
viruses it's definitely possible to do
with cell cultures and so on so do you
worry about that ever about like like
spreading I know like knowledge like the
knowledge that you have being like it
has there ever been a piece of knowledge
you don't even have to tell me what it
is but that like you've kept out of a
piece of your work because you thought
it would be dangerous for more people to
know it actually this is the only one
okay I've actually censored myself on
well well a lot of times when there's so
the origin of HIV there's there's a
bunch of conspiracy theories around that
as well and one of them sounds fairly
plausible and it's has to do with polio
vaccine research and so I don't talk
about it super a whole lot because
because there was contamination sharing
sharing of needles which we know is a
problem for HIV spread yeah yeah so it
was happening you know it was in an
after
a lot of these first early trials were
happening we don't know how clean people
were being with the the needles that
were being used for this and then
there's actually there's a there's an
even worse possibility that you know HIV
comes from chimpanzees and yes if we
were experimenting with chimp cells in
human cells or chimps and humans maybe
that maybe it actually the jump actually
happened in a laboratory so there's
there is that conspiracy that it was
then covered up and I I doubt that
that's what happened I think that the
mainstream story on the origin of HIV is
is probably legitimate and the reason
for that is that it's super hard to keep
conspiracy in the scientific community
like you would think that because
scientists are the ones that make
vaccines that they would also be able to
hush up a conspiracy or they would
actually be able to join forces and and
keep a secret but that's not the case
when you realize how science actually
works you realize that scientists are
auditories and the way to make a name
for yourself in science is to discover
something spectacular and discovering
that discovering the true origin of a
virus is something very spectacular that
any any biologist would want to discover
and so yeah I mean if it like - it seems
to me that it becomes like okay so
here's what we know about HIV we know
that it came from some interaction
between chimpanzees and humans yeah
we're some sort of accidental
contamination of fluids occurred yeah
now there are there are situations where
people are in contact with chimpanzees
because they're hunting them and there
are situations where people in contact
with chimpanzees because they're
experimenting on them yeah and so and
it's it's impossible to know which event
those hurt in but you can run the
numbers yeah
presumably and say you know how many
interactions are there really between
chimps and humans in you know like like
it's it's possible that we could have
you know it would have been possible to
get HIV from a chimp in a zoo that you
know
we're performing performing some sort of
medical treatment on right like this
yeah anytime you have an interaction of
humans and chimps there's there's a
possibility of this yeah so I guess if
you're going for the light most likely
when you just have to look at what are
the most common interactions right and
in the the possibility of this having
happened in a laboratory did scare the
scientific community enough that a bunch
of new protocols were made around
handling apes in general and the types
of experiments you can do on them like
mixing human and ape cell cultures and
so on so there was some good that came
out of this scare but but the I think it
was the World Health Organization that
that that there was actually some very
very prominent biologists were involved
in investigating this possibility and
like I'm trying remember the name of it
the biologists were involved in it but I
mean they're like the top evolutionary
biologists were called in to investigate
this independently and their conclusion
was that this most likely came from the
bushmeat trade in and the congo because
we were able to find a strain of the
same virus in the congo and we really
okay so we know like the chimpanzee
population that it came from yeah yeah
we know the exact population but the
question is is did anyone capture chimps
from that and then ship them out to labs
and yeah who knows that was the evidence
that they were trying to follow to see
if if that was a possibility and they
couldn't find good evidence for it so
okay they concluded it was probably the
meat industry or the the bush meat
industry so yeah if you call it an
industry anyway so so yeah that was
another thing that whenever I talk about
HIV I say the mainstream hypothesis is
that it came from the bush meat instead
of talking about instead of scaring
people about polio vaccines yeah and I
think he came away with a lot of respect
for you
specifically because when you're like
when you encounter like out of the
mainstream ideas that
would get written up as conspiracy
theories you take them like you take
them seriously you say okay like like
what is what is the merit of this we're
gonna analyze it on its merits and just
because it's it's against what the most
probable hypothesis is I'm not I'm not
going to mock the people saying it and
I'm I'm probably going to find they like
you you find the parts of it that makes
sense and ask interesting questions and
you see where those questions lead you I
think you really appreciated that well
yeah I mean the truth is always
strangers in fiction right all right not
always but oftentimes a stranger than
fiction so I like to think of these
conspiracy theories is poorly proposed
hypotheses right okay
people people aren't usually putting
forth conspiracy theories as testable
hypotheses they're saying that this is
what happened and that's that's what
what we're gonna see here
yeah and often I find that they're
they've latched on to one thing like a
single plausible thing that has been
ignored in the story they've heard so
far right and like the fact that nobody
is talking about this thing that to them
seems like an eminent possibility
because sometimes it actually is a
possibility um that it's very easy to
take the step from that to that's
because there's a cover-up and if
there's a cover-up then for sure this is
what's going on yeah so I don't know do
you want to get in to consume some of
your comments so yeah I was thinking so
the comments I'm about to read just a
word of warning folks they're not
necessarily kind or you know PG so it's
just the stuff that comes to me on
YouTube and I've got okay I've got
thousands of comments and I went through
them yesterday to see what were some of
the main conspiracies and so I think we
should to lighten the tow and maybe
maybe some some some light means like
you you want to do what's the music in
the background
[Music]
can I do like oh I do like like oh we we
menu kind of theme yeah
all right hold on I I did on the liver
[Music]
loop in some music for us here like 30
comments here to read I'm getting uh I'm
getting it
cutting out for me but I thought I don't
think it's cutting out for the public so
first comments so turn this down we
don't get my video my video was titled
where D new virus has come from and this
sort of provoked people to just instead
of watching the video just write what
they thought where they thought the
virus came from so is actually Hillary's
first three seconds I wish there was a
feature where you could tell like how
much of a video someone is washed before
they commented right so but but it was
perfect cuz the the title asked people
where they think viruses come from I
guess so they would just respond so the
first one is old by old virus where do
viruses come from
it's an old virus tweaked and made in
korea in korea in korea a second one new
virus comes from an undisclosed lab
hidden somewhere in the city of chicago
where the new virus has come from
communists why chicago deep i don't know
it's an undisclosed lab hidden some
hidden somewhere but definitely in
chicago where wherever it is
we're the new virus has come from it
originated in Fort Detrick Maryland that
that is a title cific was there well
there's a laboratory there so okay
Koba nineteen originally came actually
originally game they originally came
from a Chinese bioweapons lab so we got
Korea so far we've got Chicago we've got
Maryland we've got communist we've got
Chinese lab I guess yeah it's been it's
been interesting to see how like the
like there's these two strains of
conspiracies which are that the
Americans unleash this on China and the
Chinese unleash this on America yeah and
they've sort of followed the spread of
the virus so when it was just the
Chinese outbreak it was like the main
conspiracy theories for coming out of
China and they were this is an American
thing right and now that the main
outbreaks in America is this is a this
is a Chinese lab that they always
planned for this to be a pandemic well
you'll see that there's there's things
good things at deeper okay
where did new Carano viruses come from
it comes from Donald Trump you a whole
play oh there's there's no you in this
quote it says it come from Donald Trump
hey hey does that mean does that mean
you're the a-hole or they're literally
specifying the part of Donald Trump's
Anatomy yeah sorry sorry for reading
that wrong I added more information to
it was there yeah so maybe it came from
Donald Trump's a hole or maybe I'm the
a-hole for not saying that it came from
Al Trump I can't tell ya either well it
came from the minds of corrupt Democrats
ooh
fully formed corrupt Democrats so okay
I'll tell you where it came from
the elite elite someone says total BS so
this person must have watched my video
and thinks that it's BS okay so good
total BS Bill Gates funded the company
that owns the coronavirus patent it was
created in a u.s. laboratory and
released on the public enemy number one
China say hello to the new world
order in action the you Genesis are
going to kill us all ooh okay so you
were talking a bit about this Bill Gates
thing yeah
in a previous conversation so I mean I
have seen the Bill Gates like we're not
ready for a pandemic TED talk yeah
where's this Bill Gates thing come from
the Bill Gates thing comes from it comes
from a patent that is owned by a company
that he the Bill Gates Foundation helped
fund for a a neutered bird coronavirus
that is we hope will someday be used to
fight a corona virus that infects
chickens and turkeys and has been
devastating the meat industry so really
yeah so there is a Maxine so it it's
it's the precursor to a vaccine so a lot
of vaccines are made by kind of you you
I say neuter I don't know what the
actual term is I'm forgetting attenuated
I think yeah so you take a virus and you
make it so I can't reproduce or can't
reproduce very well and you use that as
a vaccine and the first vaccine was
basically an attenuated virus we
actually took a vet took a virus from a
cow the cow pox it was close enough to
smallpox but it could not replicate
inside human cells and we gave it to
humans we just scratch it into their
skin and yes specifically I think that I
can't remember the name of scientists
but he just like tried it on a little
boy yeah this works yeah because they
had noticed that that like I think it
was just people who had gotten cow pox
let's try it
it was his nephew or something and no it
was his it was his like his maids son or
something okay so maybe it was his
bastard child I don't know it might have
been yeah imagine being that kid like
okay here we're gonna I'm gonna make you
ill and now I'm gonna give you smallpox
and
you're okay yeah so the the crazy thing
about the interesting thing about this
is that vaccine comes from the word vaca
which means cow and Spanish a Latin so
yes vaccine is like cow thing
so did we describe the Bill Gates thing
okay so we'll say hello to the New World
Order in action the eugenicist
are going to kill us all that's a yeah I
don't know where the eugenics comes into
this well okay the idea is that Bill
Gates is a rich guy that is one of the
elite and he doesn't want poor people to
live okay or people that he thinks are
inferior to live I don't know where you
get that really because he spends a ton
of money on stopping disease and and and
digging wells and and giving sanitation
to poor countries and stuff so it's like
like of all the all the billionaires
that you were going to that you were
going to accuse of trying to kill all
the poor people Bill Gates wouldn't be
at the top of my list but right you know
it's all yeah but but of course II I
mean you really can't you can't really
trust what a billionaire is what a
billionaires reputation is because a
billionaire could spend however much
money he needs to to on his reputation
right so I suppose there is reason to
doubt a billionaire right to be
suspicious of a billionaire and then
we've got the so it would be interesting
that you like if you were gonna do do
you genex with the virus it would seem
to me that you wouldn't want to make a
virus that has no known cure and doesn't
like it doesn't really depend how
wealthy you are whether or not you can
escape it but I may be I imagine that in
here is also the theory that actually
the elites have the vaccine okay well
and that's why that's why people are
freaking out that Bill Gates funded a
company that owns a corona virus vaccine
or the precursor to a corona virus
vaccine you
because they think they hear the word
coronavirus bill gates patent they put
those all together and think that this
is the same corona virus infecting us
it's a completely different corona virus
it's a it's a bird corona virus very
very different the actual if you look at
the patent I've actually looked at the
patent it's genome is published there
you can actually compare the genome to
the current one different species but
because it's got Corona in the name
people assume it's the same thing and so
they did you read the genome well I just
I just compared them quickly that's
definitely something that some
next-level research for a YouTube video
I've read the entire genome of this
virus it's memory check it against all
other viruses no that would be a more
interesting like memory test than like
pi rising high you can tell me the
entire entire genome of the novel
coronavirus okay
continuing with with conspiracies so far
just just to recap we've got Donald
Trump's but we've got Gary a China
communists Bill Gates Chicago Maryland
now someone says why did this guy why
didn't this guy named China come on
so people are mad at me cuz because the
viral accused China enough did you juice
did you say China or did you like are
there mad that you didn't like so I call
the Chinese virus I got a comment
similar to this probably 50 different
times and yes I mentioned China in the
very first sentence of the video I said
this is where the outbreak started yeah
but I guess I didn't that wasn't enough
so people were upset about that okay the
next one all made the virus to punish us
okay I was wondering when this would
come out say I feel like it was all the
rage to have
disasters be like things from God to
punish us like maybe 10 years ago
yeah like when Katrina happened or
whatever um I don't know I feel like
like within the within the like Western
Christian world that's mostly gone by
the wayside yeah like I haven't heard
that that line come up and like like
Christian conservative means the
one-percent rich elite who don't need
the wee 99% anymore now they have AI
robots to make and do everything so this
is another elite Bill Gates type
accusation then the Irish came in from
leftist commies Dems and those are all
capitalized so let the commies Democrats
who hated Trump's success successful
economy and tried everything from a coup
to impeachment to get rid of President
Trump nothing worked so they allowed the
virus capital capital all caps virus to
fly its way through the world but once
again God and Trump will have the last
laugh on their evil intentions and I
think when they say their evil
intentions he means the the commies and
the Democrats Wow okay so okay what do
you make of this I'm having I'm having a
hard time peace piecing together who's
controlling what in this one it's a
little vague er yeah it's like like we
have leftists and commies and Democrats
which sounds like it sounds like they're
talking about that they like us culture
war but it doesn't seem to me like those
politicians have anything to do with
allowing a virus to fly around the world
yeah you're right you would have to you
have to blame one Airlines or whoever's
putting in the like who's ever doing
whoever's doing checks at airports yeah
this guy didn't actually say that the
Democrats
built the virus he said they allowed it
they allow it to fly around the world
yeah like if Donald Trump had its way
there would be no airlines that's
interesting
all right well I think probably we
shouldn't think too much about this one
he did stuff right I don't know I think
yeah I know like I'd like to see if
there's a now we have another Bill Gates
the reason I put multiple Bill Gates in
here is because there's so many stinking
accusations of Bill Gates there's
probably there's probably hundred sorry
were you gonna say anything else on the
I don't know I think I'm good okay so
this was the work of the Bill Gates
Foundation look it up they have
coronavirus patent I did look that up
and it's for a bird virus and it's a
near neutered version okay one word 5g
okay we got to the 5g yeah and I don't
know if you can consider Phi G to be one
word I guess it knows v generous ends
for fifth-generation so yeah I think
technically it's an initialism yeah 5g
this is you you and I have different
versions of this one that we've heard
because the one that I was getting was
out of I think it was it was like a like
a homeopathy a / anti VAX conference in
the states where this guy was had was
talking about how I've GE had actually
poisoned humanity causing our own cells
to release these viral particles yeah
and that actually there was no like
virus had nothing to do with the illness
it's it's you know our body is trying to
purge themselves of toxins and these
little capsules that well that doesn't
make any sense we have very specific
mechanisms of what this virus does and
it's very good at infecting cells it's
not a little garbage yeah
sure and then the other the other
version of the five G accusation is that
five G which is this new type of cell
phone tower right yeah
is causing people's immune systems get
messed up so we can get new viruses and
we might talk about that a little bit
later today but you know it's unclear
what 5g radiation will do to humans it's
actually unclear or it seems unclear so
it's unclear it seems like it's going it
will have if it had any effects they
would be like they would be kind of on
the scale of this electro sensitivity
thing that you've talked about and it
seems like so far we've tested out
electricity sensitivity and it's mostly
in mostly in osebo effect yeah we think
it's a nocebo effect so we think it's
people think that radiation is hurting
them that radio waves and stuff are
hurting them but we can't find a
mechanism we don't and and when people
are tested as to whether or not they can
tell if radiation is if they're exposed
to the radio waves they cannot tell you
know like in the moment so yeah but the
reason why I say that that would be like
the only effect that I could imagine is
just like on the scale of the physical
effect of 5g because it like it uses so
I was looking this up before it uses
basically the same frequencies as
microwave ovens which sounds kind of
scary
like are we setting up the world to be a
gigantic microwave cooking ourselves it
turns out that the US the US has they'll
be stringent guidelines on like what
power of radiation you can be exposed to
from a 5g tower yeah and it's 10
milliwatts
so that's like a general microwave oven
is a thousand watts so 10 milliwatts
would be one ten thousandth of the
radiation you would get from something
being in a microwave and that's like
that's not nothing right like that's
enough that you it's you know it's
obviously measurable by your cell phone
to pick up a call and your nervous
system is very sensitive it's not
totally impossible that have mild
effects on the nervous system it's but
it's the equivalent of being inside a
microwave for like one second of 5g
exposure is the equivalent of being in a
microwave for a tenth of a millisecond
so if you turn on your microwave for a
tenth of milliseconds and then you take
the food out and you see whether it's
changed that's like a scale of the
difference you'd be talking about and
that's in the US and China it's like
it's another order in Europe it's
another order of magnitude down I think
in China's two orders of things so
you're talking about like a hundred
thousands or like a million so so I
think this is probably good point a good
time to point out that while these
conspiracy theories sound really crazy
I actually am grateful that people are
spending energy on worrying about things
like Donald Trump unleashing viruses on
on the world or well left just call me
Dems
you know unleashing a virus on the world
or 5g being dangerous because you know
maybe there's this slight chance that
one of these things might turn out to be
true the interesting thing is the
certainty here each of these people has
that it's the one thing that it's their
one path yeah that's like the the
amazing thing is that there's no there's
no one putting like putting together in
these comments like a collated list of
like okay have you got a few guys
considered that like it might be a
bioweapon and then it might be Bill
Gates and then it might be 5g like you'd
think that someone might be like a Alec
Hart diner of a whole bunch of different
conspiracies and wonder like like if I
add them all up what's the probability
that that none of them have a nature
people don't tend to do that they take
they focus on a very particular one
right and let's just to give the
audience here a taste of this I'm gonna
just go through and read the rest of
these because there's like 20 more okay
I'm just gonna read in real fast we
won't talk about them individually just
to get an idea of just the spread here
so the virus the corona virus is one of
the weapons used by extraterrestrial
aliens in a war against mankind that is
a real comment and I get several like
that and some of them were joking
some of them seem very serious and so
aliens all viruses are man-made there
are no viruses in nature and anyone who
tells you otherwise is a liar or
ignorant about it again Bill Gates has a
patent and it's a bioweapon stop
spreading lies about it being natural
all is a big lie and expansive global
government's propaganda lead 'add by the
global media in favor of the elite
Israeli created laboratories 100% made
100% yeah has anyone thought about polio
because it sounds a lot like polio
that's not really conspiracy theory it
does it sound like well young polio
conspiring against us no well I think if
you don't want know a whole lot about
virus there yeah yeah they're both
viruses it came from melted ice glaciers
because of global warming I suppose
that's not a conspiracy either but
that's well that I mean that is
something that people worry about yeah
they're not the warming will release old
viruses that are trapped right right
that has been proposed as as a possible
for future but but there is no evidence
that that happened here these evils are
harbored and funded by the secret
Satanists you can find locally
everywhere ooh
so Satanists now look up you look up
your local Satanist
there's their secret but they're
everywhere easy to find the coronavirus
is created by the Americans and Israeli
army coronavirus is start from USA and
by the way a lot of the the ones blaming
America have grammar like that because
they're usually that it's English as
their second language actually I find
that a lot of people like to make fun of
people's misspellings on the internet
and saying things wrong but it's usually
because someone's speaking English and
it's not their native tongue so and most
of youtube we should respect people more
when they say stuff wrong because it
means they speak more than one language
okay viruses are aliens
end of story that when I buy that one
stone I mean whatever a definition you
want to give to aliens
I think viruses in it where do new
viruses come from God Byron another one
virus is a creation of Satan he tries to
mimic God's creations but it always
turns out to cause evil and destruction
and I got two more they come from Big
Pharma so the conspiracy there would be
Big Pharma unleashes a virus and then
they sell the vaccine right and then
last but not least they come from the
logger lugar bioweapons lab and I always
say this the wrong Tbilisi Tbilisi
Georgia so the country game that's the
capital of Georgia this is Georgia the
country not yes Georgia the country not
the state so we got the Russians in here
we got the Russians yeah so we've got
hit and here's here's the spread here of
these allegations we've got communist
Donald Trump Democrats China the Chinese
Bill Gates the Koreans the Jews
the Georgians the elites the Republicans
aliens Satanists Satan the
one-percenters
Big Pharma 5g God and Allah so those are
the the accusations and then I get made
fun of that's a it's a spread yeah this
happens multiple times people make fun
of me because in my video I say possibly
it could be this possibly you know as
far as we know this is how we're viruses
normally come from you know I'm not my
my videos it's science and in science we
have uncertainty and I like to express
that uncertainty I got made fun of many
times for that so this guy says you
don't know friend of course it was
developed in a lab you Jack a people
aren't stupid they just like acting like
they are so this is one of several
people making fun of me for not being
solid enough in my convictions I suppose
during the animation so you should have
told people exactly how and in which
laboratory inspires those made yeah but
which one which one could should you
affect a genuine problem like if I if
you had to you are gonna believe one of
these conspiracy theories like not which
which one is the most plausible like
which one do you like you're gonna go
all in on a conspiracy theory I like
viruses are aliens in this story I think
that one just tickles me because if I
were aliens I don't know I feel like the
strategy would be pretty much exactly
the same right you know you have to come
together as a global community and
combat the alien threat to kill us it's
Independence Day all over again or it's
there was that one there's the other one
that says it's a weapon created by
aliens so one is that virus is literally
aliens the other one is it it's a weapon
created by the aliens so yeah I like
that
well it's been spin fire Oh conspiracies
junk we hope you enjoy next time for our
program on do aliens have will kill them
music so people have lots of fun
comments in here Isaac says Thanos
intensifies yes I I'm curious that
people have actual questions so there's
a little bit of a lag here so it's gonna
take people a minute to to come up with
those questions so what people are
coming up with are questions I just want
to say that next week I have I will be
doing this again and I have planned
Shannon Q who was another youtuber to
come on sweetie I like Shannon and she
is a trained psychologist though she's
not worked in psychology but she's a
trained psychologist and she's now at
youtuber she doesn't their things as
well but she is going to talk about
these psychological impacts of social
distancing and we're yeah we're gonna
talk about you know what is the science
behind this a couple of different
problems that people are having so
there's that sounds like an interesting
conversation yeah I am I'm excited I am
noticing like like this phenomenon of
crisis fatigue was something that people
were worrying about a little while ago
but now I'm really seeing it yeah like
I'm seeing it in my own family
everyone's like come on like how long
can how long can we do this right where
it's like like it needed we needed to be
distancing 2 weeks ago and so we still
did distance 2 weeks ago now we need to
even more yeah but we want to less than
we did then it's you know we're just you
reset and nothing is actively happening
to you and it's like I'm tired of this
right right I think you can see this
happening all over the world yeah for me
it's going things are going to intensify
because Maryland my wife is going to be
heading in
you know Monday she starts in the ICU
she's a nurse okay Mondays tomorrow's
the day but I don't believe she'll be
working with Corona patients on Monday
because she's a she's like the she's the
backup for that so okay but probably
sometime in the week I'm I would imagine
by Friday she'll be working on corona
patients so I will have a lot of I mean
he's gonna get more and more real for me
right it the interesting thing that I've
realized I've been following this for
months because I did the animation which
took me a month and I have to make I was
aware of this before most people were
talking about it in the United States
cuz I was doing this animation
interesting thing though I I haven't
seen it for myself so as far as I know
personally the whole thing can be faked
it could be a media hoax right which is
I don't think I had that accusation in
here but I got a lot of the media hoax
accusations the first few weeks that the
video was up those died yeah those are
known yeah prominent that makes sense
but it is interesting because you know
I'm Marilyn and I will probably get it
because she's working directly with
people who have it now the her her
trainer that's training her on the virus
you know said that nurses as long as we
have personal protection equipment
nurses are probably more safe at work
than they are when they go to the
grocery store really because that
personal protection equipment is so good
but we are scheduled to run out of that
eventually if we can't if the if the
private sector can't beef up the
production and so hopefully here that
won't happen hopefully we'll be able to
beef up production in time but you know
it is it's certainly certainly possible
that her and I are gonna get it from
this even though we're doing a really
good job social distancing you're doing
our best but yeah so it's it's about to
get real from
yeah so it is it has been interesting
watching it approach like first it was
someone has it and then it was some
celebrities have it and then it's for me
it's been some of my some of my
connections connections have it yeah and
and then like B now because of because
of the lack of testing I don't know what
I don't know whether people I know have
had it which is one of the big problems
like I have a friend in New Hampshire
who's who it seems likely that she had
it and that her friend did as well
because they described all of all of the
symptoms pretty accurately and they
weren't very flu-like they were you know
like the pain in the chest and the
difficulty breathing and uhm but they in
New Hampshire you can't you apparently
can't get tested unless you're a medical
professional or you're like in a
hospital so yeah there's a lot of
uncertainty which which is unfortunate
because you'd think that the more people
can know they've had it the more you can
you can use those people strategically
like here's your here's your population
of immune folks now yeah yeah the the
problem is that we just literally don't
have enough tests they don't exist yeah
on our continent
apparently China has an abundance of
them but they're not allowed to trade
them because of trade war politic issues
right now
lovely so apparently they have them but
there's rumors that they don't actually
work that well and so we don't want them
anyways and yada yada yada so me that
sounds it sounds a little bit like a fox
in the grapes situation the CDC has
requested and they're working on it and
they requested that private sector works
on a serum test to tell if you have the
antibodies for the virus to tell if
you've already gotten it in and and
recovered so we will have that and
what's probably going to happen is
they'll start out because building these
things you have actually manufacturing
them once you have one that works takes
time what we're probably going to start
doing is randomly sample people and in a
different populations to see
how many people have got it and
recovered okay and then we'll start
selling them to individuals who are
curious and you might have governments
that give them out to individuals so
that everyone can figure out if they're
immune to it because what's gonna happen
I think is people who are immune are
going to start going out into the world
and trying to live life again and we'll
probably have businesses start to open
for them and run by them and I'm curious
to see what the internet comes up with
for the name for these people like the
the recover the recoveries something
clever some clever name we'll have those
those who have passed the gauntlets yeah
entered through the narrow door yeah and
they'll you know they'll they'll be
their own little club and the club will
slowly get bigger and bigger and bigger
and you'll kind of feel bad if you never
get it because you'll never be a part of
the club you have meetup groups that are
only for those people and those will be
literally the only meetup groups exist
yeah so that will be interesting day
walkers this is the what would Ted Ted
Ted ington says they'll be called Robert
Adsit says Mark of Cain
oof yeah right okay we got a question
from a nice will see my soul how do you
pronounce your name how do you produce
aisle I don't know
sorry I apologize but the question is
yeah I do this I do this to you this is
the problem with being a North American
with the worldwide audiences that you
butcher people's things on a regular
basis says not that I particularly
believe it that could have could have
been the virus spread before it was
initially detected absolutely the the
virus virus has always spread before
they're detected what happens is you
know a lot of the the wealthier nations
that do a lot of medical surveying and
they really care about disease control
basically any nation that's a part of
the World Health Organization and is
helping fund that they are also
constantly monitored monitoring their
own populations for new viruses but it
works like this you get someone who's
sick they go to the hospital there
tested for everything that you have
tests for it comes up negative for
everything but the person dies you're
like oh that's weird
and you kind of take note of it and it's
really a different hospitals are taking
note of it so how it works here in
Canada you know my my wife is a nurse
and it kind of takes a while for it to
really because people people die of
mysterious things more often than you
would think maybe you if it might look
like you died of the flu but you tested
negative for the flu but it might have
been an error in the test so it's not
the first two or three aren't a huge
alarm but once you get over a certain
number and I suppose any every hospital
is gonna have a different threshold for
this people start to get worried and
they're like is this something totally
crazy and new and then they alert
government officials and then it gets
investigated so this would have happened
in China China's political system is
very different than ours is as a lot of
you heard there was a attempted cover-up
in the start and I think that's we think
that is this we think of that is this
really malicious thing that only
communists do but I think a cover-up a
cover-up of a new disease here would
just be not really reporting because you
don't think it's a big deal yet or not
talking about it publicly because you
don't think it's a big deal yet but
there was that story in China this
doctor who's trying to warn people and
he got talked to like you're not
supposed to you know I'm just scaring
people you're inciting panic man it's an
accusation that's been leveled around
the world about this thing yeah and at
people have when this when it was much
more obviously a greater threat yeah and
when China was doing it yeah the
Republicans were saying that this was
that the media was exaggerating Donald
Trump was saying that the media was
using this as an attack on him yeah so
Donald Trump was trying to tell people
to be quiet about this he it wasn't a
government cover-up but he was it he was
telling people during interviews
be quiet about it so we had it this is
an it's not like a communist thing this
is a natural tendency of anyone who's in
charge of a large population you don't
want your population to panic before
there's reason to panic and you got it
it takes a while to figure out if
there's reason to panic or not so yeah
but I think like with this with this one
I have like I have heard people like I I
had a friend messaging me from
California saying like I have a bunch of
friends who think like who you know got
sick in December or January and like
they think that like they're telling me
well I probably already got coronavirus
because it was probably spreading before
we knew it and so I'm like I'm fine like
that like there there is some there is
some math you can do on it generally
right like if if the virus has has not
overwhelmed your Health System by now it
definitely wasn't already spreading in
your community like back in December
yeah that that's when it was just
starting off starting off in Wuhan and
you would have seen you would have seen
this huge spike at the same time they
did you know so if you had like a
flu-like illness in December January and
you're not from you-know-who Bay
Province in China it's much more likely
that it was something else
yeah so people are so more on this
question was it spreading before I was
detected yes but we can tell roughly how
long it was spreading by sequencing the
genomes of the various versions of the
virus and we've been doing this now long
enough we've been sequencing the virus
we we know pretty much when it got to
different nations we know roughly the
date when it first got to different
countries like like we know roughly when
I got to Europe and so on and we've been
able to track it long enough that we
know it's mutation rate it's general
mutation rate and I think it's like
Cameron what it is but we we know what
mutation rate is and if we project
backwards using that looking at all the
diversity of the viruses that exist
today because there there's about
there's a baseline genetic sequence for
the virus the the the really which is
which is based on comparing all the
really early cases and then there's the
the current versions of the virus and
most current versions are about ten
mutations different from the original
one so since its sense that first got
started there's there's been about ten
mutations that have popped up and
they're different mutations so different
like the one in America well there are
several different versions in America
that have different family trees and you
can actually look up these family trees
it's all published now Wow yes there's
an amazing website I'll put put a link
to it in the comments because I don't
remember it off the top of my head okay
there's an amazing website where they're
mapping this out in real time like every
time a new genome is sequence it's added
to this family tree this evolutionary
family tree and now are these mutations
that actually affect the structure of
the virus or they ones that like I keep
are they these point mutations that
don't actually change the results in
proteins or what are we talking about in
general we can't tell but we do know we
do we do know a region that does matter
for this virus for the shape of its
spike protein which is the actual
approaching that attaches to the human
cell so well it's one of one of them
that attaches and we do know a part of
that gene that if you tweak it it will
change the function of the virus and
that is not changed hardly at all since
okay it initiated but other than that I
don't think we know a lot of what's
functional and what's not it's yeah like
I would be curious just just because
there's like there there's some double
counting of like the translation from
RNA to protein right yeah
like are most of these just switches of
a single base where the like the codon
is the same so that the protein is
actually identical yes are they actually
changing the protein at all so yeah a
lot of them
it I haven't seen information on that
but yeah okay a lot of mutations that
happen don't affect the structure of the
organism at all there there were there
there neutral mutations completely
neutral and a lot of these ones are
considered to be neutral and yeah so
they they're finding about ten ten
mutation differences in the current ones
compared to the original ones and we
project from that they have a estimate
of when the first crossover event
happens so from animals to people to a
person they think that happened I think
it was like November ok 2019 or maybe as
earlier but October October November
somewhere around there and it's an
estimate based on the mutation rate so
it's not necessarily a hundred percent
accurate but we don't think this has
been spreading very long you know since
you know earliest is October of 2019 hmm
let's see if we got any other questions
here so what if it's just related to
population growth and the likelihood of
mutations I don't know fully this is a
danger dab let's see and he also says I
think it spread a long time before
disclosed by any country so from the
genome we can tell that it's it wasn't
that that much longer before it was
disclosed before it was discovered so
China a lot of people are upset that the
World Health Organization is praising
China because this thing unleashed on
the whole world so we should be angry at
China right well that they're praising
China for the the quick discovery of
this and reporting of it because you
know the it was within months that
they've discovered it and then reported
it so far as we can tell from the genome
and that is impressive I think I think
Canada would would be a similar
turnaround time us would be a similar
turnaround time but it's still it's
amazing that we can do this like and
pass we couldn't yes true like like
Sarah's it was how long was it before we
even knew that it was a virus yeah I
don't know an HIV HIV I was years before
we figured it and even even when we knew
that AIDS was a thing it took us I think
it took several years to find AIDS as
the cause or sorry HIV is the cause the
actual virus is the cause so it's um
it's spectacular what we're able to do
now with with modern technology and with
this world health organization - which
is here to try to report on this stuff
and prepare prepare share information
between countries that don't naturally
want to share information you know so
it's there's there's a there's a good
question
that I'd be interested in in getting
your take on from the great owl how big
their question is how do we address the
actual threat that the conspiracy
nonsense actually poses and I think my
question to you would be like like when
you're looking at all these conspiracy
theories how much of a like how much are
you worried about them like like what do
you see as as the threat is it a threat
is it is it more of a curiosity how do
you think about this so some of the
conspiracy that some of the conspiracy
theories were really dangerous because
they were saying that it was it was a
media hoax and you shouldn't worry about
it right so those ones are obviously
dangerous the other ones I think I think
what's happening is people if you look
at that list
some people are accusing God and stuff
and you're Satan and there's no I don't
think there's any danger and those
accusations really I don't know we're
not gonna offend Satan but you know if
you if you if you say it's God's
punishment for a particular thing yeah
then you could you go on to to use that
to persecute people for a thing yes like
homosexuality oh man yeah but I think
that the the the most destructive thing
about this is that people are choosing
it's very obvious when you look at the
accusations that people are choosing a
group of people that they don't like
whether it be Israel or the United
States
or Democrats or Republicans and they're
demonizing them by saying that they
created the virus and that's a what
that's doing is it's just increasing
like distrust of other people so mmm
this is a do you think like do you think
that that's new new animosity like do
you think people are actually like is
the virus succeeding at evangelizing
more people towards these positions or
are you just always gonna have a certain
number of people who dislike groups of
people and they like latch on to the
story of the day I think if you're
divided this far and now you're accusing
each other of a virus you know divided
this far right there and I think it's
just it's just like another another you
know way to separate us and so that I
think is really dangerous like we know
that this the political divides are
dangerous like we don't want the
Democrats and the Republicans to hate
each other as much as they do right now
we don't want yeah Chinese and Americans
to the European Union didn't go back to
being a bunch of countries with
complicated armistice armistice is
against each other because that never
seems to go well yeah yeah wait I mean
there are problems with a you know I've
heard all the complaints about having a
New World Order or like a one-world
government and I understand those
problems like I think it's it's very
dangerous to consolidate everything into
one one power source obviously but also
you need to have like the world is way
too small now or way too connected we
can our economies are connected we can
easily destroy each other with nuclear
bombs with genetically engineered
weapons wait
like the dangers are way too high for us
to be hating each other we can't afford
to hate each other the way we did in the
past it's just not possible we can
destroy our species we have the power to
do that now so anything that's really
dividing people or causing each other to
hate each other is a problem and this is
just these conspiracies are really are
ceding extra little little little seeds
of hatred
and so that's that's one of the things
that I don't like about them yeah you're
not you're not making me optimistic for
for the future they're yeah
innocent innocent until proven guilty is
something that we should consider when
it comes to did China create this virus
or did the u.s. create this virus
innocent until proven guilty is I think
something we should all be clinging on
to here because yeah it's definitely
possible for a country to make a bio
weapon that's super easy like for
especially one of these large nations
like Russia or China or the US or like
we can do it it's not hard but to accuse
someone of that it's a major accusation
and we need to we need to let the
agencies in charge of figuring that out
you know like it our military spends
time trying to figure this sort of thing
out our military intelligence I think
its citizens we should be like look we
voted for our leaders we built this
government we have an agency that does
this and intelligence agency does this
we're going to go ahead and just trust
them and not hate our neighbors until we
have to right yeah it also seems like I
don't know that there's a there's a
problem there's a I don't know like a
game theory problem or something of I
don't know like like when people are
super like right away it's like okay not
only do we have to blame China but like
China's going to have to pay for this
like I'm seeing I'm seeing articles like
this are like in like respected papers
you know respected journals like like
McLean's in Canada which is one of these
sort of like I know slightly
intellectual magazines you know when is
China going to be held accountable for
all these things I know it it disturbs
me because like what is your end goal
are you like that there's this there's
this instinct in humanity which is like
leave aside for a moment like imagine
that there is a group you can blame
for this and also imagine that if you go
with your gut and like rain down justice
or whatever you're going to set off an
even larger catastrophe because that's
we all have the ability to destroy each
other now like is I don't know we need
to be able to override even that like
like you've even that human like desire
for like we're gonna we're gonna get
them like I don't know cuz at some point
at like it doesn't look like it's this
time but at some point somebody is going
to do something that's like genuinely
bad yeah and genuinely harmful to the
world and if our response is we're gonna
you know we're going to sanction them
we're going to bomb them in a state
where everybody has the capability to
destroy everyone else your your desire
for just justice causes your own
destruction and that's like yeah I don't
know yeah I think worrisome I think like
yeah what I've been telling people is
that no matter where this virus came
from we have to work together to fix it
and you know that's the most important
thing and you know there's there's now
this kind of like accusation contest
between the US and China where there
were American officials that were
publicly accusing this as being a lab
leak or maybe a bioweapon and so then
Chinese officials started accusing of
being like unleashed by the United
States during during a war games thing
and so like and there and China stopped
well according to the article that I
read China stopped censoring conspiracy
theories against the United States in
their social media that was and they
would but they would censor him if there
was conspiracy theories against the
Chinese government and then here in the
US of course we don't censor anything we
try not to we sent her stuff we
definitely censor stuff but not not at
this
extent so the like yeah we we don't want
that to spiral out of control we don't
want that that that hatred in and you
know even if this was a bio weapon that
leaked or a bio weapon that was
Unleashed what we want to do is fix it
right control the bio weapon and then
and then we want to figure out why this
happened and then we need to deal with
like you know it let's say this was
intentional
worst-case scenario this was this was
intentional well we need to figure it
like how do you how do you deal with
this now like how do you yeah how do you
slap someone's hand how do you punish
someone for doing this is punishment
what we should be going after is that
correction how do we correct whatever
group was responsible for this how do we
fix this problem so it's um yeah it's
yeah it's a mess yeah and there's this
general problem it seems in in our
development of technology where
technology's destructive technologies
are produced and you need to develop
technology further because protective
technologies need to be more advanced
than destructive technologies yeah but
then once you've advanced your
technology enough to have protection for
last year's stuff you've developed your
abilities for even worse things this
year and I'm not sure I like where this
is going like from for my for my
perspective the ultimate version of this
is like like when I start to think about
like the potential for like global
instability and global breakdown yeah
then like the only solution I can come
up with is okay well we need to way to
invent some sort of thing that's smarter
than us that can get us out of these
problems you know and like take this off
your hands because we're super able to
resolve it and then you guys it's like
well we could solve it with a super AI
that's benevolent and then as soon as
you get that then you get into the
problems of making a super AI that's
that accidentally destroys you which
like
all technologies it's a lot easier to do
that yeah it makes something meat
destroys than something that perfectly
preserves your fragile little state of
the world that you need to keep yeah
yeah I don't have answers I don't have
answers for know how this is supposed to
go I didn't either I guess music music
and I do have it I do have this hunch
that the thing we don't want to be doing
right now
is hating hating people who are
different than us because and letting us
our selves grow in fear of them so this
was malicious let us forgive and move on
that's the best way the only way for us
to really have a future I believe there
was another question a while back about
do we know if this came directly from
bats or if there's a secondary animal
that give it to humans and what that
animal was and is there new information
on it there's none that much new
information on it okay the most recent
thing that I saw was a published report
saying yes pangolins could have been an
intermediate but yeah you had that in
your video so that's still that still
seems like a definite possibility yeah
everything in my video is still where
we're at so it's we still think maybe
pangolins but we haven't found a perfect
virus in penguins that would be like the
intermediate between bats and humans so
is their wedding penguins that we know
that's like closer than the 90% mass in
bats yes so there is a the spike protein
in penguins is an almost identical match
to this new version okay and it but the
rest of his genome is very different so
what we think is that there was a
crossover event so when two viruses
infect one cell so if if a penguin had
its Pangolin version that's got the
protein spike is very similar to humans
and it got infected with a bat
coronavirus
it could transfer that gene to the bat
coronavirus this is there's reassortment
and recombination that happens in
coronavirus in viruses in general
recombination is the process that
happens in coronaviruses and it's where
you can get genes that hop from one
virus to another and I should someday do
a video explaining how that work because
it's really interesting but yeah I'd
love to do that but we know that that
happens in corona viruses and it happens
naturally in corona viruses and we think
that may have happened here but we want
to find the version of the virus that
has both the spike protein similar to
the current one and has the the rest of
the genome that's also similar to it so
we've got a we we've got a bat genome
that's more that's really similar but
the spike protein is very different and
we've we've got a Pangolin version where
the spike is the same but the rest of
the genome is different so okay that's
that's where we're at with that we think
that it went from bats to penguins and
then to humans from there do we think
that there is still like this virus
still does exist in an animal reservoir
somewhere like this precise one probably
one of the problems with it though is
you can actually have back contamination
where humans give it back to a group of
penguins right so it gets really tricky
to figure this out it gets really icky
yeah but it but it is doable because the
virus has mutated so much in humans now
that we should be able to see at this
point if it was a recent transmission
back into penguins we could tell if it
was a retransmission versus DNA original
virus yeah yeah but if they were
transferring back and forth to each
other
early on it would be hard to tell so
it's it's messy but if we do find a a
wild species with a very similar virus
we can say quite confidently this is
where it came from
we're not there yet we're almost there
we're not there yet
all right John I think I'd better go and
eat some lunch
[Music]
I didn't actually have a breakfast they
got a place today and I well folks I
hope your questions were answered well
enough if you can send more questions
specifically about if you can email them
to me so John yeah access to medications
are people who need them so thanks for
the music Tim and they say you and
Marilyn you're alright so long for now
stay curious
yeah